hey this is Lauren zagary with motion
science and today I'm going to share
with you five Pro tips I use every day
in my work as a professional motion
designer
[Music]
[Music]
first let me welcome you to the first
episode of the quick tips and better
workflow Series where I will showcase
the tips and tricks that change my
motion design game the first tip I have
for you today is using shortcuts to
speed up your workflow if you don't have
it already and want to follow along I
highly recommend downloading the FX
console plugin by Video Copilot what I
see a lot in motion designers is that
they use the control space shortcut to
quickly search for effects however there
is a hidden feature if you go into
settings here in shortcuts you can
assign the effects that you use the most
to numpad Numbers if I press OK back in
our composition if you press control
space you can access those effects super
easily so if you're a blur maybe a
gradient the fill
a level Hue saturation you get the idea
another underrated feature for FX
console is screenshot comparison
here if I want to take a screenshot I
can press Ctrl space select the little
camera and right next to it we have our
Gallery if I open this Gallery we have
all the screenshots we've taken for all
our projects
here let's say we click on one image and
want to compare it to another I can
control click
and see them side by side we can then
compare type composition layouts color
and do this with as many as four Images
here's three
here's four this is very useful and I
don't see a lot of people using this if
you want to export one of these
screenshots you can access the FX
console plugin and the third icon you
can save it to a PNG a JPEG or just copy
it to a clipboard and paste it into a
team's chat for example up next I will
show you how to create organic looking
vignettes what I see a lot of people
doing when it comes to vignettes is to
Simply add an adjustment layer with the
CC vignette effect this gives us a
somewhat perfect look and it doesn't
feel really organic in my opinion here's
a better way of doing it you can create
a solid and draw a mask around the
portion of the image you want our Focus
to be on this Mask doesn't need to be
perfect because the more organic it is
the better it will feel you can then set
this mask to subtract and play with the
Feathering here I used 496 pixels and
play with the expansion a little bit you
can also tweak its opacity to get a
desired look when it comes to coloring
vignettes I never like to select a pure
black color so here I added the fill and
I picked a very very dark blue basically
one of the darkest color in my
composition to take this a step further
we're going to create a blurred vignette
around the edges of our composition to
do this I'm going to create a shape
layer add a gradient wrap to it make the
ramp shape radial
take this to the center maybe and play
it with the position of the end wrap and
then gonna add e levels and play with
the gamma whatever is black will be
clear whatever is white will be blurred
can of the round scatter to get rid of
any banding
and since our text is on the upper right
corner let's select the center and place
it
right here it doesn't need to be perfect
something like this I went ahead and hit
our blur map layer we named it to blur
map I created an adjustment layer with
the camera lens blur effect under blur
map we can select our blur map layer
with the effects and mask option
selected here I use 25 just so we can
see it just a little bit too much but
maybe 15 maybe 10 yeah it's very subtle
but it makes a difference
just so it's not as sharp around the
edges the third tip today is all about
creating a soft glow to our composition
I went ahead and created an adjustment
layer renamed it to soft glow I then
added a fast box blur to it with the
blur radius set to about 50 pixels I set
the blending mode to screen and this
gives us a nice glow but it's a little
bit too overpowering if I press t for
opacity I can adjust its levels just
like this takes the digital feel out of
our composition before after I usually
try this trick in most of my projects
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
I recommend experimenting with different
looks and see what you can come up with
our next tip today is all about creating
some lens Distortion to simulate what a
camera does in real life I went ahead
and created an adjustment layer renamed
it Optics and added the Optics
compensation effect here you can tweak
the filter view up to create a fisheye
effect let's keep this very subtle to
fix the edges we can add a Transformer
effect and scalar composition by two
percent this makes our text a little
less digital and add some subtle
Distortion we can also create the
opposite effect by first disabling our
Transformer fact and clicking reverse
lens Distortion tip number five is all
about tweaking values mathematically
what I mean by this is let's say here we
have other adjustment layer we've
created today and let's say we found the
blur vignette to be a little too much
what I mean by tweaking values
mathematically is that you can use
mathematical operators in every field in
After Effects so let's say 25 is too
much we can say I want to buy half as
much so you can divide it by two and
maybe a little more so plus five and I
usually tackle uh every value I change
using this method let's say the glow is
a little too much I can press the
opacity and say maybe three times less
so divided by three maybe five times
more so times five and this is how I
perceive two tweak values now to wrap up
this video let's take a look at what
we've done one more time we started off
by having an image some text and a look
applied to it we then created a vignette
manually by creating a mask adjusting
its feather and expansion we then
created a blur map for blurred edges and
apply an adjustment layer with our
camera lens blur effect and our blur map
selected we then went ahead created a
new adjustment layer with a fast box
blur set to around 50 and our layer to
screen we tweaked its opacity to create
a soft Haze on top of our composition to
create some lens Distortion we created a
new adjustment layer applied the Optics
compensation effect and fix our comp
edges with the transform effect let's
use our screenshot comparison trick to
compare the before and after
here is the before here is the after I
like this one much better I hope you
liked this video as much as I loved
teaching it if you learned something new
or want to share your own tips let me
know in the comments below until next
time this is Lauren daggery with motion
science
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]